this morning we continue our special
series kindness 101 with steve hartman
sharing stories that are built around
themes of kindness and character could
use a lot of that today and the people
who have mastered those qualities well
today's lesson is determination steve
and his kids introduce us to a mechanic
who proves anything is possible with a
little elbow grease
good morning i'm here with my daughter
and co-teacher merrill hi everyone today
we'll be talking about determination
as always we start with my brother
emmett at the dictionary desk emmett
good morning uh determination is to
never give up yeah it's like inner
strength you know how you guys talk a
lot about how muscular i am uh no you do
most of the time
you're not even that strong compared to
other men
either way yeah i think of determination
like mind muscle
it's what keeps your brain going when
the going gets tough and even though
it's an invisible force it can
accomplish great things
how great well let's look in our library
and pull one of my favorite stories
about this potent force called
determination
i really want to be a doctor when i grow
up whenever his two little girls play
doctor and dream of becoming one someday
let me take your heartbeat doctor master
mechanic carl allenby is flooded with
the feeling of deja vu you wanted to be
a doctor oh yeah but that wasn't
realistic not where i came from though
i grew up in east cleveland which is a
very impoverished city we were on
welfare and i remember the powdered milk
government powdered milk and
block cheese
and because they were so poor young carl
quickly set aside his professional
aspirations and focused instead on
becoming the best auto mechanic he could
be so this was the par store where i got
all my customers from so you would work
on cars in the parking lot of the parts
store oh yeah sometimes till one two
o'clock in the morning eventually he got
his own shop and for 15 years he did
okay until one day he decided to ratchet
things up
in 2006 carl enrolled here at ursuline
college his intention was to get a
business degree to help him manage his
repair shop
but there was one hurdle
a biology class he couldn't understand
why he had to take it and he put it off
as long as possible i'm a business major
what do i even care about biology but i
went to class and in the first hour of
being there
i knew what i wanted to do with the rest
of my life
all those ideas of wanting to be a
doctor just came rushing back
and to make a long story short the car
doctor dr carl allen
is now a doctor doctor
we love you
a few years ago carl graduated from
northeast ohio medical university and
today he's an emergency medicine
resident at cleveland clinic akron
general hey miss fiora by all accounts
carl is already an exemplary doctor
partly because according to his
supervisors he worked so long in a
garage that cannot translate be shocked
actually i think it's some of the
customer service this is dr rebecca
merrill could you imagine right now
going and learning auto mechanics no
but carl said he'll do our oil changes
so
fortunately carl now has more important
repairs on his mind but this old auto
mechanic also knows that whether you're
working under a hood or staring down a
hatch can i have you open up your mouth
otherwise your success hinges on your
drive i would hear people say well carl
it's going to take nine years to become
a doctor yeah and i'd say well nine
years are going to pass anyway so i'd
rather be someplace i want to be than
some place that i could have been
and there's the prescription yeah for
the i can't do it blues
i'd rather be someplace i want to be
than some place i could have been
smart guy even by doctor standards which
is why we were determined to have dr
carl join us today
good morning hey how's it going steve
how do you instill this in kids this
determination
let them know you'll learn much more
from your failures than you will from
your successes and that they're not
going to be good at everything that they
want to do
earlier emmett defined determination as
never giving up and i think you're
saying one of the keys to never giving
up is just recognizing that you're not
going to always succeed yes yes and it's
okay what are you determined to do next
i want to learn how to play the piano
and if you look behind me there's a
piano in my daughter kennedy here
actually plays is your dad any good at
piano
guess not
so he goes from a mechanic to a doctor
to a musician
yes
we'll see if that works out okay thanks
so much for joining us really appreciate
it steve it was awesome to see you again
take care little ones
feeling determined yep
good
because you don't ever want to wonder
where you could have been
we'll see you next time until then stay
kind
[Music]
you can tell he's kind did you hear dr
carl say take care of little ones i like
that his daughter kennedy kane go
kennedy that is the trifecta a smart
you're talking about man who's a doctor
yes he can also fix a car with his bare
hands and play the piano yes and he can
fix my body i'd like to change your oil
and take out your appendix how about
that
from fixing cars to fixing people and
don't you believe that he will actually
be able to play the piano too i believe
it kennedy was a little reluctant when
she said is he going ah
that's what daughters do he has
determination kids are very very honest